it's a phrase we hear over and over on
Twitter whenever someone criticizes
morally troubling anti leftist tactics
used by members of the right they say
what are you some sort of coward what
are you worried about my principles the
phrases meant has arrived the supposed
moral pruning of those who criticize
they must think themselves high and
mighty whining about virtue or some good
hard-nosed old-fashioned getting the
dirt and fight them tactics would do
these worries about the right and wrong
just hamstring the right my principles
are liability why can't those weaklings
just get over the supposed moral purity
and fight in the trenches now I am no
fan of political cowardice I wrote an
entire book called bullies in which I
blasted left character assassination
techniques I routinely speak on college
campuses and conditions that are less
than physically secure I am more than
happy to tell people things they don't
want to hear in political debate and
I've been threatened more than once on
national television by the way for my
trouble but I am also a fan of
principles I'm a fan of principles
because without them politics becomes
meaningless even those who criticize my
principles have their own principles
the my principles crowds highest
principle is supposedly defeating the
left that's the entire argument if you
stick with your wishy-washy principles
about civility you'll lose and if you
lose my principles will be destroyed but
as it turns out many of the people who
mock my principles have no actual
principles other than empty tribal
victory never was that clearer than this
week when several members of the
self-appointed Trump ardent defense
squad went full social justice warrior
invading a Shakespeare in the Park
performance of Julius Caesar that
depicts President Trump a Caesar
screaming liberal hate kills they
stormed the stage called the audience
member Joseph Goebbels and held up the
production those who objected to this
obtuse behavior were simply being
hamstrung by my principles they then
proclaimed except that there were no
principles at stake here what was the
supposed principle perhaps the principle
was that artists shouldn't make art that
invokes images of violence inflicted on
a president then why weren't they upset
about a rodeo clown dressed up as
President Obama in 2013 maybe the
principle was that radical rhetoric
leads to violence then why weren't they
upset when candidate Trump urged his
followers to quoc protesters maybe the
principle was that shutting down others
free speech is bad a sort of ironic
lesson for the left then why didn't they
say so rather than claiming that the
contents of the play justified their
shutdown and why would this be a good
strategy given that the self-immolating
hard left's free speech shutdowns have
backfired so dramatically that even
Obama
Elizabeth Warren and Bernie Sanders have
been forced to condemn them no there
were no principles here other than
tribalistic hands high left foolishness
unfortunately that seems to be the order
of the day for a few select on the right
I'm old enough to remember when the pro
Trump right justified Trump's behavior
on the grounds that he had to build a
wall and rescind Obama's executive
amnesty now only Ann Coulter has the
guts to point out that Trump hasn't done
either of those things and then he just
enshrined for all time Obama's executive
amnesty I'm old enough to remember when
the pro Trump right assured
conservatives that it would hold Trump
to account if he were to fail to repeal
Obamacare now it's ignoring the fact
that he called watered down Obamacare to
mean and push for broader funding what
are the principles I thought my
principles had to go so that they could
achieve their principles but they seem
rather blyde about the collapse of some
of their supposed in core precepts which
suggests that maybe there are some on
the right who just want to fight and
they forgotten why they fight and even
how to fight all the matters now is
winning even if they have no idea what
winning looks like other than the other
guy losing I'm vetting Shapiro this is
the Ben Shapiro show
[Music]
okay lots to talk about today I'm going
to talk about at length the Asaf loss
which is just hilarious I have been all
evening I would last night I was
laughing my ass off it was just
spectacular the good news is that he
will at least have a soft landing he's
probably going to end up I think his
rotating co-host I'm pod save America
because that's probably the only place
you can go from here but before we get
to any of that and there's a lot to talk
about it is a vindication for president
Trump just because left turned it into a
referendum on Trump when it really did
not have to be but before we get to any
of that first I want to say thank you to
our sponsors over at helix sleep so I
don't get a lot of sleep which means
that the sleep that I do get I need it
to be just any of you fast asleep I need
to be comfortable I really need to get
my quality sleep since I can't get
quantity sleep due to the two kids in my
house under age 4 well that's where
helix sleep comes in helix sleep
mattresses the most comfortable mattress
in America for my money helix sleep comm
slash been the way that it works you go
on their site and ask a bunch of
questions about you let's sleep on your
side or your back how much do you weigh
what's your body type do you like the
mattress to be breathable do you like it
to absorb heat what how do you want the
mattress to be and then they send it to
you in the mail you can actually have a
mattress that has two separate settings
for you and your spouse then they send
it to you in the mail and you open the
box and it inflates it right in front of
you it's a foam mattress and then you
just put on your bed and you're good to
go and you can try it out for a hundred
nights and if you don't like it you can
send it back for free they will come
pick it up they'll give you a 100%
refund no questions asked you won't have
to do it because the mattress is
SuperDuper comfortable so go to helix
sleep calm slash spend and get $50 off
your order
that's helix sweet calm slash men get 50
bucks off your order right now helix
sleep calm slash Ben use that flash Ben
so that they know that we sent you as
well get that $50 off that keeps them
advertising with us so that we can
continue to bring you the show ok so
last night John Asaf loses by five
points to karen handel in the georgia
six the democrats had poured thirty
million dollars thirty million dollars
into this ridiculous race now it is
important to note the reason that they
thought they were going to win this race
is because Hillary Clinton only lost to
Donald Trump in this district by one
point in 2016
the reason that this was somewhat
delusional is because Tom Price who is
the Congress person
who just left to join the Trump
administration as Secretary of Health
and Human Services he had won the
district in the same election cycle by
23 points in other words there are a lot
of Republicans in the district who
aren't fond of President Trump but who
also aren't gonna vote for a Democrat
just because they don't like President
Trump Trump wasn't on the ballot last
night Karen Handel was on the ballot
they kind of like karen handel they
certainly like karen handel a lot more
than they like john Asaf and the
democrats attempts to turn everything
into a referendum on Trump really
backfired against them in a significant
way last night again they come tons of
outside the district money in John Asif
looks like it they found the one man in
America nerdier than I am and they ran
him for Congress and then they ran him
from a district that wasn't even the
Georgia SiC but I think it's important
too to look at how the media played this
race because it really played into why
the Democrats lost here the reason the
Democrats lost is because the media ran
a race that the voters in the districts
were not interested in running they're
all jazz because back in April Asaf won
48% of the vote 49% of the vote that's
because 1000 Republicans were running
and so Democrats were able to
consolidate their vote and nobody paid
attention to the special election
because it was assumed that Republicans
were going to win it until Asaf came
very close to winning in the in the
first round then in the runoff
Republicans actually showed up to vote
that's kind of the short story but
Democrats were claiming from the very
beginning that this race was going to be
a referendum on Trump is Trump doing a
good job or a bad job he's doing a
crappy job he's Russian spy etc etc and
therefore John Nassif is definitely
going to win some random district in the
middle of super bourbon Georgia so here
is CNN covering the race this is right
after the the original round in which
Asaf missed winning 50% also will face
off against Republican karen handel in
june for the seat formerly held by trump
health secretary tom prize in a contest
seen as a referendum on trump's
presidency and a preview of next year's
midterm elections President Trump taking
credit for the results hailing the
runoff as a win despite also strong
showing tweeting despite major outside
money fake media support and 11
Republican candidates big R win
with runoff in Georgia glad to be of
help the president was personally
invested in the election bashing the
Democratic contender and a barrage of
tweets and even recording a robo call to
urge Republicans to get out and vote us
off we'll raise your taxes destroy your
health care and flood our country with
illegal immigrants President Trump beat
Hillary Clinton in this Republican
stronghold by just 1% last November CNN
the rest of me didn't wanted to play
this as it's all about Trump it's all
about from now the realities in the
district Trump is not particularly
popular Mitt Romney won this district in
2012 by 23 points the same margin of
victory for Tom Price in that same
election cycle so Trump is not that
popular and so the Democrat spot okay
Trump is investing himself here and
that's why it's very very important that
he's going to lose and you can see that
the fallout from that was really funny
last night because CNN which had played
this whole thing up as it's going to be
a referendum on Trump form is going to
lose this and then everyone's going to
realize how toxic he is then he's going
to lose 100 seats and the house in 2018
little early to say that you know that
last night on CNN this is going around
because very very funny you can see the
media reactions on CNN the actual
footage last night on CNN all the
Democrats looking like they want to die
this is the second funniest thing I've
seen in last year the first funny thing
of course is election night when it
looked like the entire Democratic Party
was going to reenact the the last scene
from was of our dogs Reservoir Dogs
anyway here was on CNN last night -
David's point earlier about Democrats
kind of and Gloria about looking inward
and trying to figure out how to run in
the Trump era this was supposed to be
the districts that they could have done
that because it is wealthy it is
educated and the kind of voters who are
in this district was supposed to be the
kind the Democrats could pick off from
the Republican if the Republican ends up
winning it throws the whole democratic
strategy into kind of up in the air and
I kind of have to figure it out all over
again all right we get it we gotta take
a quick break oh well more with all
and this picture was the one that was
making the rounds last night because you
can see all of the Democrats on set
looking like they're just contemplating
life's meaninglessness that you know
life doesn't mean anything and then you
die and spend all eternity just
moldering in the ground not a thought in
your head because you're dead it's like
they just realized about nihilism and so
it's just I love this shot so it is
pretty spectacular stuff I love it I
love it and so did the Democrats made a
bunch of mistakes in I'm gonna talk
about all the Democratic mistakes here
because we've talked a lot about the
failings of the Republican Party because
the Republican Party is the governing
party right now they have a majority in
the house they've majority in the Senate
they have the presidency and they're not
getting a lot done but the nice thing
for Republicans the Democrats are awful
at everything they are awful at
everything and so they're a bunch of
sort of hot takes from the left that are
worth discussing plus the real reasons
why they actually lost this election so
before we get to anything else with
regard to why they lost this election I
think that it is important to stay but
the real reason that the Democrats lost
this election is because they have a
perverse notion of how these elections
work they do not work because they're
going to somehow convince Trump
unfriendly Republicans to flip and vote
Democrat that's not even what happened
in 2016 it wasn't a bunch of Democrats
who were unhappy with with Barack Obama
who flips to Trump so much as it was a
turnout game the fact is the entire
margin of victory in a lot of the swing
states was lower turnout by Democrats in
those swing states by percentages
particularly in the black community and
what happened in Georgia 6 is Democrats
really needed high Democratic turnout
and low Republican turnout by
nationalizing the race by giving it tons
of publicity instead what they ended up
doing was driving Republican turnout up
they elevated Republican turnout and by
elevating Republican turnout they ended
up losing because here's the reality
folks a bunch of people who reluctantly
voted for Trump which he won the
district by one a bunch of people who
reluctantly voted for Trump are not
going to start voting for people who
backed Nancy Pelosi just because you
went in and you voted for Tom price but
not Trump does not mean now you're gonna
flip and vote for John Asaf that's
idiocy and for Democrats to think that
is really stupid this is why to make the
whole thing about Trump he's really
really dumb for a marginal vote maybe
that matters but what this is really
about is motivating your base the
Democrats made them
using from to motivate their base but at
the same time they castigated Republican
voters who voted for Trump by talking
about Trump Russia and Trump's corrupt
and Trump's evil well let's say that
you're a voter in Georgia SEC or in Ohio
or Pennsylvania or Wisconsin or Michigan
and let's say that you voted for Trump
you held your nose right if you weren't
in love with Trump you're like a lot of
voters in ga6
you didn't love Trump you thought he's
better than Hillary but you know I'm
really uncomfortable with this they pull
the lever for him and now the Democrats
spend the next eight months saying the
Donald Trump is the most evil person in
the world give power to Nancy Pelosi how
many of those people do you think are
going to flip the answer of course is
zero none of those people are going to
flip and in fact is going to drive you
to the polls because you hate nits Nancy
Pelosi is actually less popular than
Donald Trump her current approval rating
is 29% nationally if she's 10 points
below Trump and Trump's in bad shape
so again the Democrats made a very large
boo-boo when they started targeting
these what they called Republican swing
voters instead of trying to drive out
their own base it's exactly the same
mistake actually that they made in 2016
when they started targeting Republican
swing voters in Michigan as opposed to
trying to drive out their own base so a
couple of things number one ah scoffs
chances in this district were inflated
from the outset this is a congressional
race not a race about Trump not a race
about Trump the same year the Trump won
by one Tom Price won by 23 points second
Democrats nationalized this race with
outside money so by pouring money in
from California Asaf received more money
from California than from Georgia in
this race he spent thirty million
dollars and now he's complaining about
money in politics which is just
hysterically funny by doing that they
ended up destroying their own that the
credibility of their own candidate what
they really needed to do was keep this
race under the under the radar that's
actually what happened in the South
Carolina district there's another
special election that happened yesterday
Mick Mulvaney who is now the director of
the Office of Management and Budget Mick
Mulvaney Szold district there was a
there was an election yesterday the
South Carolina fifth District and the
Republican only ends up winning by three
Mick Mulvaney won by 21 and Trump won by
18 in that district so the idea that
that that was a really close race should
scare Republicans South Carolina 5
should scare Republicans what
Republicans should hope is the Democrats
continue to nationalize every race
continue to elevate every race
that is polarizing to Republicans and
Republicans will then turnout in South
Carolina five nobody even knew it was
happening and Democrats almost were able
to sneak in and steal a victory in South
Carolina five a district where Trump was
again won by an enormous margin so if
Democrats hadn't nationalized this race
with outside money it made it look like
Asaf was basically a carpetbagger coming
in with California values that have done
a lot better here the third thing that
Democrats did wrong is they got
Hollywood involved so Hollywood was
deeply involved in this race it was
ridiculous he had Alyssa Milano tweeting
out last night that she needed a hug to
which every male in America said sure
happy to provided and Hollywood got
involved by Robo calling and sending
money and making a big deal out of this
race this is exactly the same mistake
again that Hillary Clinton made by
turning the DNC into a rerun of the
Emmys when you go to do you really think
a lot of voters in Georgia are deeply
concerned about lena Dunham's take on
the georgia vi do you really think that
karen handel slams John Asaf on this
during their debate and it was telling
it made a difference that's why so many
of your contributions have come from
liberals of California New York and
Massachusetts it's why you're supported
by Nancy Pelosi and folks it matters
it's no wonder that my opponent didn't
want to do the Atlanta Press Club debate
it was going to be aired on CNN we're
all folks from around the country all of
his liberal supporters were going to see
it and the faith John all saw was going
to collide with a real John a saw who is
a Nancy Pelosi back liberal okay and
that was the entire point that is why
John Asif lost
karen handel very solid Republican wins
to see pretty easily for things that
again Democrats made Trump the focus and
by making Trump the focus they didn't
just go after his policies they said
listen Trump's policies are not great
and Trump is kind of scuzzy instead of
doing that they did what they've been
doing all along apocalyptic rhetoric
Trump is the worst person ever if you
voted for Trump and someone tells you
that Trump is the worst person ever you
tend to buck against that you do okay
this is like telling somebody that their
girlfriend is kind of a jerk you tell
someone their girlfriend is kind of a
jerk even if they know deep down their
girlfriend is kind of a jerk they're not
going to respond well to that
the same thing holds true here even
people in Georgia sex you didn't like
Trump
still like Trump better than Pelosi and
that's the fifth point Democrats still
have that albatross of Nancy Pelosi
hanging around their neck and finally
I'll stop didn't live in the district
and it's made a difference when you
combine the pack who's getting all sorts
of California money when you combine
that with the Hollywood support when you
combine that with the nationalization of
the race and making it about Trump well
you end up with is this image of a guy
who's carpetbagging it in from another
district
he's a documentary filmmaker with
California support and here he is trying
to steal a district in good old Georgia
again karen handel hammered aasif on
this during the debate and it really
hurt him so John I guess what I would
like to know is exactly who are you
going to vote for in this election got
the question okay well I think secretary
handles referring to my residents which
is a matter that I've addressed
transparently throughout this campaign I
grew up in the 6th congressional
district I was born and raised in
Georgia
unlike secretary Handel who was born and
raised in Washington DC
actually it is of concern to the people
the 6th district that you do not live in
our community and while I was born in
Washington DC I didn't get to pick where
I was born but the fact is I've been in
Georgia for almost as long as you've
even been alive you might live just five
minutes outside of the district but your
values are nearly 3,000 miles away in
San Francisco and her hitting him again
about the California values and that was
the telling point now what's funny is
the Democrat responses to this I want to
get to the hot takes from Democrats over
this whole thing and why exactly it's
it's indicative of why they're going to
continue losing if they keep this up but
before we do that I want to say thank
you to our sponsors over at the us CCA
so you wake up at 2:00 in the morning
and somebody's breaking in your house
and you have to grab your gun and you
have to shoot them first of all you
don't know you freeze up because you
don't have the training and then
secondly if you do shoot them you're
afraid that the cops are going to come
and arrest you because just because you
shot someone coming in your house in a
state like California doesn't mean that
you won't go to jail that's why you need
the u.s. CCA not only do they provide
training they also provide you the
defense resources you need in case
you're in a situation where you do have
to shoot someone in self-defense that's
what US CCA is for to protect you before
during and after a self-defense incident
well right now when you go to defend my
family now calm it's too
then my family now dot-com you can
actually enter for five chances to win
1776 dollars to buy the gun of your
dreams and all the ammo you need for an
awesome summer at the range and to
defend your family it's a really really
cool thing they're doing right before
July 4th 1776 get it you have five
chances to win 1776 dollars when you
register over it defend my family
now.com to enter for free and you have
five chances to answer for phrase defend
my family now calm again go to defend my
family now calm not only do you get all
the services of USC CA but you get one
of those five opportunities to win 1776
dollars for the gun or ammo of your
choice
super cool we are so pleased to be
working with USC CA doing tremendous
work on behalf of gun owners across the
United States and perspective gun owners
who just want to win 1776 dollars to buy
a new gun defend my family now calm okay
so the democrats have reacted to the
Asaf loss in the same way they reacted
to the hillary loss it is almost
impossible to overstate how off the
rails democrats have gone in the
aftermath of hillary losing they just
could not deal with hillary clinton
losing the election and so that's why
they went into this whole Trump Russia
collusion thing this is why they went
into the edge of the election was stolen
from Hillary Clinton it's why that
castigated the American voter is racist
sexist pig and homophobe Ling down on
their own stupidity they're doing the
same thing now and last night was a good
indicator of that this is the crowd at
Asaf party you know his defeat party is
what the crowd was chanting over at his
over his defeat party
okay so they're chanting this is what
democracy looks like tell me what
democracy looks like as opposed to Karen
handles crowd who apparently are
fascists of some sort and whenever
Democrats say this is what democracy
looks like what they really mean is look
at all the funny-looking people around
here look at how we're all diverse and
such look at look at there are so many
different colors and so many different
races and so many different genders and
so many different everything this is
what democracy looks like the
implication of course being that people
on the other side are homogeneous white
people straight white males who hate
America and hate people of diverse
colors and orientations and such is this
is such a mistake by Democrats but this
is what they continue to promulgate
because when you lose you have two
choices you can either determine why you
lost and try to fight against that or
you can blame everybody else on earth
you can blame everyone on the planet
except for yourself and that's what the
Democrats have done they've decided to
blame everybody so here are some of the
dumbest Democratic responses to all of
this number one in the category of
everybody all the voters are terrible
and Jill tulip ovitch she is a feminist
writer she wrote on Twitter quote at
what point is this not a failure of
Democrats but toxic vindictive voters
willing to elect hateful bigots
okay I know karen handel Ashley I know
karen handel relatively well actually
karen handel is anything but a bigot
karen handel is a charming gentle woman
she is she's terrific I really like
karen handel personally a lot and the
idea that she is a hateful bigot and
that everyone who's voting for Democrats
is just wonderful but everybody voting
for Republicans is evil is really
despicable Jill philipovich continued I
know it's more important it's more
convenient to blame the party for just
not convincing people but what kind of
people vote for candidates like Hanzel
or Trump first of all karen handel did
not really utilize Trump support in this
election cycle it was Paul Ryan and the
NRCC
that came in and saved Karen handles
bacon the NRCC put tremendous resources
on the ground they put like eighteen
million dollars on the ground third
anything was 13 million 18 million total
came in for karen handel
they put that kind of money on the
ground that was not Trump those knows
Paul Ryan who did that handle and Trump
could not be more different in terms of
temperament in terms of positions as
well but Jill philipovich has to blame
the Crouch says at some point we had we
have to be willing to say that yes lots
of conservative voters are hateful and
willing to embrace
bigots some are even motivated by
bigotry there's no winning if Democrats
keep their soul maybe we should instead
try to convince all of the people of
color and women to turn out instead of
try and convince hateful white people
etc this is what Democrats did in 2016
this was a massive lose and Democrats
are going to continue to maintain this
Sally cone always can be counted on for
a take so hot that it that it's toasts
your pop-tarts in the morning here is
its ally country tweeted quote best
thing that could come out of the GA six
result is for Democratic Party to
finally give up its self-destructive
obsession with centrism yes I'm sure
that if you had run a Bernie Sanders
wild left Nancy Pelosi candidate in
Georgia 60 would have won never mind the
fact to turn handle one because she was
able to link John Asif with such people
definitely Democrats please run to the
hard left the third thing was we need a
hug group this is what Sam Olano
she said group hug get in Luke Haag
weird I mean I'm alright and then
finally over at the Washington Post
there's a reporter named Paul Cain who
theorizes that asaf lost because he was
too genteel says well he's just did more
passionate that would be better
Asaf chose the high-priest route instead
of the fierce warrior it was civil
disobedience rather than civil unrest
and he still lost by an even wider
margin and they almost forgotten Parnell
this would be the candidate in the South
Carolina v so the idea is we all have to
act like Trump now we have to yell and
scream and be brutal and all this and
then we'll win no you won't win then you
will lose then Trump did not win because
he was all of those things he won
because Hillary Clinton was the worst
candidate in the history of American
politics and Trump's aggressiveness was
an asset
even if his brutality was a drawback you
can be aggressive without being brutal
and and Democrats seemed to fail to
acknowledge all that but please
Democrats keep those hot cakes coming
really appreciate it now I do want to
discuss what this means for 2018 and how
Republicans have to be a little bit
careful in their interpretation of these
results they may be getting over their
skis and in terms of the triumphalism a
little bit early but for that you're
going to have to go over to Daley
wired.com right now and become a
subscriber for $8 a month you can
subscribe to daily we're calm now if you
want to subscribe and get access to the
mailbag watch the rest of the show live
get Andrew Clayton's show live hit get
access to his mailbag we have new shows
that are coming if you wanna get that
for $8 a month you have until July 1st
to do that because on July 1st we are
raising our rate
not going to change rates for anybody
who's currently subscribed so if you
subscribe right now then you get in
under the wire for eight dollars a month
this is also true for the annual
subscribers if you go and become an
annual subscriber right now not only do
you get in under the wire before we
raise rates of July first but also you
get a free signed copy of this year book
say it so I me and my dad and it's all
about dads and sons and baseball I have
my dad on last Friday's a wonderful guys
also terrific writer and say it so is
the name of the booking a signed copy
signed by me and so you can get all that
with the annual subscription you just
wanna listen later go over to iTunes or
SoundCloud make sure that you subscribe
I think Google Play has it as well make
sure that you subscribe and then you can
download the show we always appreciate
your your not only listening to the show
but also leaving a review so if you do
that that also helps let other people
know through the itunes algorithm that
we exist we always appreciate it we are
the largest conservative podcast in the
country
[Music]